THE ROLLER COASTER DESIGNED TO KILL ITS PASSENGERS
In 2010, architect and PhD candidate at the
Royal College of Art in London, Julijonas
Urbonas, from Lithuania, decided to attempt
to design a method of euthanizing people that
they might even enjoy.
His solution- the Euthanasia Coaster, which
he designed and built at a precise 1:500 scale.
It’s a roller coaster that could seat up
to 24 passengers and give them a good time
before ultimately killing them in a painless
and euphoric way. How does it work?
First, the coaster takes the passengers up
1,670 ft (509 meters) (which would make it
about 3.7 times taller than the current tallest
roller coaster in the world, the Kingda Ka).
Next, the passengers would plummet down the
other side reaching a maximum speed of over
200 mph.
Up to this point, it’s been all fun for
the passengers, assuming they like roller
coasters that is. If they, like me, find the
free fall sensation to be extremely painful…
well, up until this point, they’re going
to have a bad time. And after, well… that’s
not the best either.
You see, what comes next is that, after the
coaster hits the bottom, it then goes into
a loop, which at the speed the passengers
would be going at would exert about 10 G’s
of force on them, enough to drain their brain
of the necessary life giving nutrients and
oxygen from their blood.
Six more loops follow this first big loop,
with the loops progressively getting smaller
and smaller in order to maintain the 10 G’s
of force throughout the loops. With the loop
section designed to last 60 seconds, all without
blood being able to get to the brain, the
prolonged cerebral hypoxia *should*, according
to Julijonas Urbonas, render the vast majority
of the passengers dead. (I’m skeptical-
and am going to have our resident paramedic
writer Scott answer whether this would really
work as part of an upcoming article on how
long someone’s heart would have to stop
for before there would be no point trying
to resuscitate them.)
Of course, if any survived, they could then
just be run through the coaster again. Or,
as they’re all likely to be passed out,
at that point I guess someone could just shoot
them or lop off their heads or something.
They wouldn’t be conscious, so probably
wouldn’t mind if some less fun method was
used to kill them at this point.
After all the riders are dead, the bodies
could then be unloaded and new passengers
put aboard, and as Urbonas said
Thanks to the marriage of the advanced cross-disciplinary
research in space medicine, mechanical engineering,
material technologies and, of course, gravity,
the fatal journey is made pleasing, elegant
and meaningful…
In theory, only people who wanted to be euthanized
would be aboard the coaster. Further, the
single long ride up to the top isn’t just
for needed potential energy, but also to give
the passengers a chance to consider their
decision for a couple minutes as they climb.
At the top, they choose to get off if they
want. And, in fact, according to Urbonas’
design, the coaster would not continue down
until those aboard all pressed a “fall”
button, else the coaster would just stay there.
Although, how they’d get down if they didn’t
want to die isn’t clear from the picture
of the design…
But, according to Urbonas
The rider has a few minutes to contemplate
his decision and his life in retrospect. He
would find enough time to adapt to the height
and get through a series of imaginary fatal
falls, while realizing that the objects on
the ground are getting smaller…The slightest
movement of the car would trigger intense
heart-beating and goosebumps and most importantly
it would test your decision. Therefore the
very top of the tower is an ideal place to
give the very last word.